salut maroni comment ça va
oui paris pour aller rencontrer un
agriculteur de saint leu qui a bénéficié
d'une aide du département pour aménager
son terrain
ok promis je verrai sur place et qu'elle
produit vous venez avec moi on va voir
ensemble ce que notre agriculture pays
fait pousser sur son exploitation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à saint leu sur le domaine
de jean kléber agriculteur local depuis
plusieurs années l'an dernier jean
kléber a souhaité augmenter sa surface
de plantation un projet qu'il a pu mener
à terme avec l'accompagnement du
département
bonjour monsieur rga ma douzième c'est
un texan john un peu poussé ici mais ces
poussettes des papayes décroisait des
concours de groupimo et des magazines et
puis les filles la passion et en clis à
côté les vagues des cabris d'échec et la
demande l'aide du département pour quel
projet il faut dire friche les terrains
et comme on l'a connu certaines du
département ne nuit pas dit en ligne
dans des villes en formation en maladie
les écuyers s'il a payé ben moi la
partie attaque le département explique
adina monet matisse qui il faut soigner
les papiers nécessaires de quelle
manière bandas et accompagna où vous
êtes idiot mais tous les partis foucault
était et vous amener à préciser pas
bronzer diamant d'être
maîtrisé et jusqu'à l'est merci monsieur
camara aussi merci messieurs les ctom et
benjani bonne journée
afin de soutenir les agriculteurs locaux
à développer leur activité
le département propose des aides
spécifiques pour permettre concrètement
à nos producteurs pays d'augmenter leur
potentiel
c'est le travail de la cellule
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs dont
fait partie florence experte dans le
domaine
bonjean florence sont absents alors
dites-nous de qu'elle est jean kléber at
il pu bénéficier in the wind aux travaux
légers d'aménagement foncier qui permet
de mettre en valeur une nouvelle
parcelle soit pour planter plus soit
pour aller vers la diversification pour
monsieur rangama salua permet
d'augmenter sa surface de production ces
tunnels plafonné à 4000 euros est
financé à hauteur de 90% et au delà de
l'aspect financier
comment est-ce que vous accompagnez
humainement des agriculteurs comme
monsieur rangama qui n'ont pas forcément
le temps de remplir des dossiers alors
l'accompagnement est basé sur l' écoute
ça nous permet de connaître et de
comprendre les difficultés des
agriculteurs
donc il ya deux accompagnements quand
les agriculteurs comme ceux rangama ne
sont pas forcément disponibles
donc on vous tient des permanences
les dossiers sont préremplies pour ceux
qui veulent être autonomes donc là on
les accompagne bien au niveau de leur
dossier est ensuite l'année d'après ils
peuvent faire ce lord aussi sur le plan
administratif c'est bien le département
qui s'adapte à l'agriculteur et parle
inverse et le fait d'être sur le terrain
on voit concrètement la pertinence de
notre accompagnement et des ateliers
partout merci florence merci alexandre
c'est une relation de confiance qui se
crée entre les agriculteurs et le
département une relation à taille
humaine pour permettre à jean kléber et
à d'autres agriculteurs de se sentir
écouter et accompagner dans leurs
projets
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'information sur les aides aux travaux
d'aménagement foncier n'hésitez pas à
contacter la cellule d'accompagnement
des agriculteurs
vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affiche sur votre écran le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous emmène
découvrir le dispositif r plus il
s'adresse aux bénéficiaires du rsa qui
souhaitent reprendre une activité
manuelle et s'inscrire cela dure et dans
le monde du travail
[Musique]